was denken sie über die kontroverse die
ihr buch ausgelöst die frage ist haben
schriftstellerin 60 von echten personen
inspirieren zu lassen
das wird ja viel darüber geredet wie
sich die filmbranche jetzt eine neue
situation verhalten soll hollywood
antwortet darauf mit immer größeren
immer teureren in bombastischen filmen
viele nationale kinematographen sind in
der krise während frankreich nach wie
vor ziemlich gut dasteht
das hat sicher auch was mit leuten wie
olivia lasten gelungen das gefällt mir
nicht wir über frauen reden stetig da er
behandelt sie wie ein objekt nicht
gefällt er das weiß
die verkäufe stürzten habt das ist total
verrückt die leute lesen bücher auf dem
smartphone lesen nicht auf dem tablett
eine andere generation kann hier
zwischen den zeilen geht es um zwei
paare den verleger und seine frau die
von juliette binoche gespielt wird und
um eine affäre die der schrift oder seit
jahren mit der frau des verlegers hat
legen des manuskriptes ich bringe es
nicht auch sicher bedacht ist mich
verstanden
da lerne ich doch zwischen den zeilen
gelesen denkst du was du etwas weiß
sonst eher recht sich auf die artbildung
viele verschiedene menschliche
beziehungen und darin liegt der vorzug
des französischen kinos wie auch dieses
films das eben kein themen kino bietet
sondern immer wieder aus der nähe auf
diese figuren schaut auf diese menschen
schaut wie sich zu den großen themen
unserer zeit verhalten müssen er findet
dafür auch keine großen lösungen aber er
schaut in vielen kleinen situationen
sehr genau hin was macht diesen film
nicht anders ich habe gerade gesagt er
hat meine manuskript abgelehnt
was soll ich denn da machen
so ungefähr ist der ton dieses films der
für olivier assayas eher ungewöhnlich
ironisch leicht wenn wir dich
distanziert trägst du nicht leonard
warum fragst du das in einer beziehung
ist doch nicht das a und o du bevorzugst
du richtig wäre doch nicht weil wir sind
seit 20 jahren verheiratet und damit mit
diesem sehr schweren und ernsten thema
geht oliver assayas auch sehr leichter
und lässige weise um das macht diesen
film sympathisches macht ihnen auch
gelungen das macht ihn zu einem der
größeren filme dieses jahr wachstum aber
das lernfest ich habe keine lust darüber
zu reden aber es geht voran
gut gut gut gut also erfahre ich nicht
mehr
nein nein